this is the two o'clock talk about
clocks and cork instructions I apologize
to those who we're already at the boot
camp because the talk is going to
overlap a little but still I'm glad that
I got some more time to talk about
something that's really close to my
heart and that's just how you make these
qm a complete constructions with all the
different kinds of clocks first I'm
going to tell you though that we're
trying to get a problem that would have
a strong promise so that means he would
look easy but instance you will be still
hard and how this promise how strong it
is relates to the eigenvalue gaps of the
Hamiltonians that are involved then I'll
give you a slight history of how we have
shown these results with the help of
such over history state and then I'll
give you quite a few constructions of
how do you actually make it with details
with these clocks and finally I'm going
to ask a couple of questions to fit into
Fernando's talk afterwards about the
quantum PCP conjecture and whether we
can reach it possibly with all that I'm
going to be talking about here so let's
start with hamiltonians we've got
hamiltonians they've got spectra and
they've got gaps so this is the first
kept that we're going to be talking
about the gap on the bottom from the
ground state to the first excited state
the second gap that we're going to be
talking about in this case is the gap
between a case where we have a problem
with a local Hamiltonian we're asking is
the ground state energy small or is it
high and the difference between these
two is going to be the promise gap this
problem is difficult because we can map
anything in the protocol qma to this
type of hamiltonians so the cume
protocol this is the only thing that is
protocol in my talk is that we have a
very fire circuit where we can verify
quantum witnesses and accept them or not
when a problem is solvable or the answer
to the problem is yes then we accept
good proofs with the high probability
and we don't accept bad proofs if the
answer is no or any we don't accept
anything more than a B and here this
difference is the promise the tough
question is is there an acceptable
witness for this circuit and in the
Hamiltonian formulation can ask is there
a particular Hamiltonian that
corresponds to this verify circuit
that's nearly frustration-free or that
has a very low energy or basically
whether the energy is low so that
promise translates in Hamiltonian
formulation into the Promised weather
Hamiltonian is not very frustrated and
the energy is low or quite frustrated
and the energy is higher than something
something more than some region note
that the eigenvalues could possibly fall
in here it doesn't really matter this is
the eigenvalue gasps this is the promise
gap what we would like we would like
this promise get to be large so maybe
one over some small polynomial may be
constant maybe even more than that how
could we possibly have that you mention
that i had a local hamiltonian and maybe
its has is not really frustrated and its
ground state energy is low or maybe it's
a different hamiltonian 0 which which
case it is and it's grass seed energy is
higher now I'd like to get a procedure
that would take this Hamiltonian in an
unknown case and then possibly like add
some more terms to it saw that what
would happen with these cases with these
ground state energies in these two cases
would be that they would get away from
each other and I would increase the
promise gap this is something that we
would like to get and we don't really
know how to do it I'm going to tell you
how to increase the promise get slightly
sorry okay we have we have no we have no
clothes are going further I'm going to
increase the promise get from 1 over L
cube to 1 over l squared in this talk
okay all right so but give me some we
would but we don't know how to really do
it using the usual circuit encoding call
construction based ideas so whatever i'm
going to be doing now is not going to
help much so let's when in a eat i stop
that was supposed to be here in this
world workshop he said that like we're
not going to take the match where or
well-trodden path of cloak instructions
because this is not leading anywhere
well it leads to quite some quite a few
fun results and sadly ETA is not here so
I'm just going to sketch very very
briefly what what are his no new ideas
and then you should go talk to Don about
those how to do things different why
small egg and value gaps result in small
promise gaps in these problems generally
are hamiltonians we can write them as
sons of two terms and then in yes cases
we can satisfy both terms so basically
this one is not very frustrated this one
is not very frustrated and an overall
ground state energy will be low in the
no cases there is no way that we can
build have everything in the ground
states of one and the other at the same
time so maybe the ground state will be a
mixture of ground States and excited
states in both cases but still if these
gaps are small the overall ground state
energy can be still pretty low and how
low can it be we're generally using the
geometric lemma which is talking about
the lowest I ghen that eigen value of a
sum of two positive semi-definite
operators where you can get it from the
minimum of the gaps in this small get
this small gap and then some geometric
factor so if one of these gaps is small
the promise get or the lowest i can
value of this sum in the no cases it's
going to be small so it's not going to
be very helpful and i'm going to tell
you why in these core constructions this
gap is small we can't really make it
bigger or we don't know how sorry yeah I
didn't understand this slide can you go
over everything again right in the yes
case we have two terms and we can make
both not frustrated and there is a state
where the energy for this Hamiltonian
will be like near 20 in es cases in
depend on what these gaps are you it's
not important in the null case there is
no way that I can satisfy this term and
this term at the same time that means a
ground state of a sum of two terms will
be some combination of probably these
four states and when these gaps are
small its energy will also be small
so I am saying that when your
Hamiltonian in your construction is made
out of two things and one of them has a
small gap then when the system is
frustrated the lowest energy will be
still pretty low do you assume that oh
no I don't have to this is going to be
something that we're going to be seen
you know in the top today you're
assuming that there they've run energy
is 0 for each of them yeah yeah or or
let's say they could be shifted I'm just
asking can I take the lowest energy in
both cases so let's talk about gaps of
hamiltonians what kind of gaps we know
for local Hamiltonians so first we know
Hamiltonians with constant gaps where we
know that for example in 1b we have
enough area law and also then algorithm
for finding ground States this is this
is this shouldn't be here right and for
2d we would like to get an aerial oh and
here are working on that and examples of
constantly kept Hamiltonians are for
example the Heisenberg XXX spin chain in
1d where after i canna details again
levente sake have shown that it as a
constant gap or for example an example
that you might not know is a biased walk
in 1d so which is the work of state
you're walking you're jumping from one
state to another into another into
another and jumping one way is preferred
to jumping back and you can also do this
in a coherent way just with the
Hamiltonian like this there is a
projector and there's a small bias and
this has a constant game these are
constantly champions second type we have
Hamiltonian said of a universe
polynomial gap these are the ones that
will appear in our slow constructions
and the classes of Hamilton's that we
know that falling here are some of them
are np-hard some of them are cute
my heart but we really don't know how
hard it is to look at or fine ground
states of inverse polynomial get
Hamiltonians that only work on qubits or
that only work in 1d we only have these
hardness results for higher
dimensionality of goods or in higher
dimensions oh but not for few bits it's
both right yeah right are you talking
about eigenvalue grabs or promise gaps
I'm talking about eigenvalue gaps so I'm
just saying until I give you a
Hamiltonian can you find its ground
state this is this is the eigenvalue gun
so if I have if I give you a hamiltonian
that is a constant gap and it's in 1d we
now know how to find its ground state or
approximate it right if I give you a
Hamiltonian at all that could be like a
critical system in 1d and as an inverse
polynomial get like the transverse field
Ising model or a quantum walk on the
line that one has a this one has a gap
that goes like 1 over N this one has a
gift that goes like 1 over N squared and
the question is can you approximate the
ground state can you figure stuff about
it and for some cases we can for some
cases we don't know for some cases we
know is ridiculously hard when we have
likes a polynomial gapped
one-dimensional high dimensional chase
but there are no Q&A with cumin our
industry source for this kind of there
are your winners win the eigenvalue with
it in either but you got there no we
don't need any it's a polynomial capable
so this is the class of polynomial I
kept qma and I think that one was shown
oh that's all isn't it Fernando your
result where we're off of people are
trying to get the quantum version of the
valley and Buzz irani theorem what's all
that oh that's you okay so other than
you should you should be telling you the
results so this polynomial again and
then unique unique PMA and unique you
see ma those things are related there ok
so we there are no q a hardness results
as far as I know right I don't have here
made them do it yeah yeah so I thought
if you were answer to tomorrow is it
somehow there are no cure is a hardness
results Lord why for not four cubits not
for cute it's not for arbitrary geometry
all right let's recap for for the people
that did over here or on the string
polynomial I kept Hamiltonians we only
have n p or q SI ma hardness results we
don't have PM a hardness results okay
and then when there are exponentially
small gaps then these things would be
hard how big could the gap possibly be
could it be bigger than a constant no it
couldn't because when we have our local
Hamiltonian with a constant degree
it can have a gap that's at most a
constant the reason for this is that
imagine that i'll give you the ground
state and i'll make a schmidt
decomposition of the ground state so
this is one cubit and this is the rest
and i have two terms in there because
it's just let's say it's a cubed and i
will change the stake i will just
exchange these two states and what
happened i have probably changed the
energy of only a few terms the constant
number but this state is orthogonal to
that state so that means there must be a
low-lying state that's at least a
constantly or at most i constantly so we
cannot have a gap that would be scaling
with the size of the system again that
again okay this is all I game elegant it
is possible that we could get a promise
get that would be bigger this is
something that we're aiming and another
question that stays here does the
genesee help or just cause trouble and
this is an unresolved question so the
knees even we have more solutions so for
example we have like 10 dimensional
ground space is it easier to find the
ground states for quantum hamiltonians
or not and we don't know and we would
like to all right this is preparation
for two games promise so low energy or
high energy for the ground state or the
eigen value gap of a hamiltonian itself
now you're going to connect these things
and i'm going to tell you about this
history state and a ground state history
state as a ground state construction
classically we are encoding a
computation or we can look at snapshots
of a computation on how the computations
progressing and we can compare and check
that in every step everything was
happening as advertised because
classically we're computing on strengths
and we're looking at strings and we can
compare the one by one and it's easy to
see whether in from step here to step
here what was supposed to happen happen
when we have quantum states and imagine
that we were encoding a quantum
computation and make taking pictures of
it and then we are comparing whether
this step was really related to the next
step if the states were products we can
do a swab test
and we can compare to love these things
but if the states are entangled when I
do a swab test now cannot really do
anything with it so comparing entangled
States is hard and that's why oh we
developed a different way for this and
the way is that for example I have two
states that are related by local
transformation so there's only one of
these qubits it's been changed by a
local operation now I will label these
states by something that I will call a
clock so this is a state and has a label
and this is the other stated and has a
different label now I want to compare
these two states and they related by the
clock changing from 0 to 1 and a unitary
happening on the data or the other way
around the unitary beam I'm computed on
the data and the calm of changing from
one to zero and now when I have these
two states that are labeled with a clock
I can compare only be starts so just
this qubit this cubed and the clock and
if the clock is small or local now it
was just one cubit I can check and do a
swab test with an operation so it
wouldn't be just a simple swap it will
be a swap and change and see I get in
plus one eigenvector and if I do I know
that they were related as they were
supposed to now when I now take
snapshots or a comp or the full
computation so this is a full quantum
computation and this on top would be the
labels how far in the computation mi
imagine that there's a little puppet and
I'm moving the puppet and how far this
control has gone this will be its label
and this will be the data how much have
I computed already this is the history
it's a uniform superposition over the
whole computation what kita has done is
he has written a Hamiltonian for which
this history state doona from
superposition was the ground state
ground state of many terms so he wrote
projectors that were exactly killing
this histories and altogether what
resulted was a king of local Hamiltonian
where this was his ground state and it
has these components it had an encoding
of a clock and this is what we're going
to be talking about now so terms that
were checking whether the clock is what
it's supposed to be that I have a [ __ ]
more than ever second it's checking
state progression meaning that if I have
a particular state in the superposition
the Phi D and T then there has to be the
next step in the superposition then we
have another term that's checking
whether the output the final state is
something that my original verified
circuit would accept and then we have a
term that's checking whether the state
in the beginning was initialized so that
I was not computing on something that
was prepared for me but just really on
zero until this is what peter has
written down and now we're going to
delve into the details in this so we got
to have a clock workshop so how do you
make a clock this vector T first we need
a system that ticks so we'll have a
certain number of states like for
example this is one state another state
and the state should be related locally
so I change a couple bits only and I
move to the next thing second I should
be able to write a Hamiltonian or less
um of projectors or terms like that for
which the uniform superposition uniform
superposition of our tix would be it's
only grounding the next thing that I
want to do is I want to have a system
which has identifiable states so that
I'm when I look at a state I can look at
a few key bits only and tell what time
it is but I don't have to like do some
big big holding and finally if I have a
system that has many more States than
just the clock state then some of them
are bad like broken plots that are not
ticking or whatever so we're like these
people are just doing weird things there
so you should be able to detect them
then be able to like separate them from
the good stays so these are my design
criteria and let let me give you the
simplest possible
the simplest possible clock is a walk on
the line so imagine I have a line of
stage 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 with transitions
that work like this you go from one
state to the next day so for one to two
and then you also can go back from two
to one the Hamiltonian is the sum of
these transitions and as a matrix is
just once on the off diagonal in this
basis this is a clock so far as
transitions how do i change it into one
that has a uniform super position as a
ground state I would make this into a
sum of projections these are projections
on states that are anti symmetric in the
following two so that means if there's a
state that has a two plus three let's
killed by this projector but if I
haven't stayed it's only like a two then
it will have will be projected I will
not have a zero this Hamiltonian is
positive semi definite and as a matrix
it looks like it has once on the
diagonal halves here and minus half on
the attack then when i subtract the
identity when i look at what the ground
state is whenever the grounds of a state
that would be a candidate for those it
contains the term one if it has zero
energy meaning that it's killed by all
of these projectors then it has to have
the two in there because otherwise it
will be not orthogonal to 1-2 then women
has a two he needs to be orthogonal to
the term 2-3 so it has to have a plus 3
and if it has a 3 it has to be
orthogonal to the third and 3-4 so let's
go out of four and so on all the others
so the only ground state of this
Hamiltonian is the uniform superposition
and when I look at the matrix i can
subtract identity and basically what
this matrix is is a quantum walk on a
line with eight points so like some
endpoint loops with some strength and
you can solve this then it has cosine
like I can vectors it as I can values
they go like two cosine p the Pisco like
KP om and the gap of this Hamiltonian is
1 over N squared and this is the basic
thing that will appear in all of our
clock instructions this
1 or n squared where our clock ticks on
n states and the first excited state of
the clock above the ground state is
quite close to now we don't know how to
do it without this one over N squared
gap but this is also the best that we
can do and week and we do no worse than
that that's also ending point so this is
a lie now let's do something that's more
complicated than a line because this is
not local so far we have we had states
that were like 1 2 3 4 5 6 how do i
encode them I can encode these states
into a palace clock so this is a clock
that here on top it runs like this they
run forward it can run back part and
it's transitions are two local at 10
goes to is 0 1 1 0 goes to a 0 1 or here
10 can go to a 01 I identify a state so
make sure what time it is we're just
looking at a single point where the
excitation is then if I want to have a
ground site as a superposition of these
i will use projections that project onto
the anti-symmetric combinations of 0 1
and 10 which means if there is a 10
there has to be a 0 1 and if there's a
10 there has to be 0 1 so the ground
state is a superposition over all these
however this product this clock has a
problem the problem is that this
Hamiltonian has invariant subspaces
depending on how many excitations are
there in the system how many ones do we
have so for example there's a subspace
with a single excitation with two
excitations or with no excitations and
this is not a cop this is not moving
anyway this is just dead and this is not
a clock that would go like one two three
four five but it's a clock where the two
excitations are moving whichever way
they want so to do to select only for
these I need to do some kind of tuning
and the tuning would be that I actually
add terms to my Hamiltonian that prefer
single ones and hate to ones that are
next to each other and by doing this
carefully you can select only this
subspace and the uniform superposition
with
in that subspace to be the lowest state
and this is doable so you add terms that
prefer one that prefer excitations but
hate whenever two excitations are next
to each other so we have minus Z and
then you have 0 + ZZ or something and
you need to tune their strengths 11
needs to have like 1 over n over the
compared to the other straight and when
you want to tune for these higher
subspaces it's harder and harder how
does this rule out okay because we have
this term and we have this term that's
that's like hating and liking the
excitations and this one is how you
should think of this one is stronger
which means that a candidate ground
state needs to be close to the ground
state of this which is the excitations
moving around which means that at some
point they will meet each other and they
will not be liked because they will be
this x factor so overall the ground
state will be close to whatever we
wanted right and its beak we can make it
close enough and show what the gap is
and the gap will go like 1 over n cubed
then or n to the fourth so the ground
state will be like this a superposition
over the excitation moving let's have a
second clock the second clock will be a
domain wall clock so here it's just
excitations or stings up moving to the
right or moving back so basically how
many of them i have here gives me the
time this is a domain wall clock meaning
because there are spins up and spins
down and it's a single domain wall so
it's always we will be this way or this
is something that though already kita
have is called a unary clock now this
clock has two local clock checking
meaning the bad states that are none of
this form so for example states that are
like zeroes and ones and stuff like this
appears where there's a zero before a
one while good clock states are always
once before zeros so any domain wall of
this type is something we don't like
then we identify States tell where the
time is by looking at two things at 10
or now the time is too because the 10
the domain wall is exactly here i can
write projections which will make sure
that the uniform superposition over the
domain walls will be the ground state
and the projections are three local they
go like 100 goes to 110 that's how i can
go forward i need to look at three
places at a time to have it unique and
all of these terms together this setup
plus the endpoints fixed to 1 and this
endpoint fixed to the 0 so i have a
single domain wall in the system the
ground state will be like this a
superposition over all possible good
states with a single domain wall and
this clock was used in qatar use
construction to show that 500
hamiltonian is chemical it because this
now is three local for transitions and
what you can do you can add to these
transitions these terms in here and in
here you're going to write in u dagger
and you
which means that like while the club
goes over something happens to the data
and altogether these terms are five
local this looks at three clock cubits
and two data Cubans so this is kita is
five Oklahoma talk and how does this
relate to the to the walks this
Hamiltonian takes that initial state and
makes it go to this one to the next one
to the next one into the next one or
possibly and that's an invariant
substance you never get out of that
substance with a Hamiltonian or there is
a different invariant subspace with a
different initial state so these
invariant subspaces are labeled by the
initial state of the data and these are
the states of the clock plus there is a
sub space where there's just whatever in
the clock subspace where they're these
not states with not a single domain wall
and these these subspaces don't mix and
that means when we are analyzing and
we're looking for the ground state or
fourth of the gap you will be enough to
do it subspace by subspace and this
subspace is a constant away so it's the
lowest energy in there is at least a
constant while in these subspaces we can
just rename these towers or phase ii
it's a line and do our oral analysis
that we did for a quantum walk on a line
so we're looking for transitions from
state to the next state we do it with a
projection term like this and we can
show that the history state it's the is
very close to the ground state and we
can also add terms that will check
acceptance and initialization and then
we can analyze and find what the lowest
energy state is what the excitation is
and so on in conclusion the way that
works in the yes case when we have a
Hamiltonian whose ground state really is
low that coal is mapped from an
accepting computation the ground state
will be long in the null case we need to
find a lower bound on the state on this
energy and the way we do it we look at
that subspaces these are the bad clock
states and good clock states then we
forget about them because they have a
higher energy then we divide it into
history
and nonuniform supper positions we can
forget about these again and in the
history states we can be by Deb subspace
but before that we already know that the
gap within that subspace is 1 over l
squared because the Hamiltonian is just
to walk on a line then we divide it into
well initialized and badly initialized
states and now we have these well
initialized history states but in the no
case none of these is accepted there's a
different subspace of accepted States
and now what's the lowest i can value
now of two terms this term is like we
like histories and this one we like
accepted states and we cannot make all
of them 0 then usually we use the
geometric lemma which looks at the gap
of one of the Hamiltonians to get of the
other of Amazonians end of it on a
geometric term and in Qatar's book you
get like else 1 over l squared here and
1 over L here altogether 1 over L cubed
and that will be the promise gap for the
five local Hamiltonian that's clear a
complete so in conclusion here we have a
verifier circuit that possibly accept or
not witnesses we map it to a Hamiltonian
that's fine local and if this is not
likely to accept anything before except
something only with a small probability
the lowest i can value here will go like
stop over L cute well if this circuit
accepts a good witness then the energy
of the history of the computation on the
witness this history will have a very
low energy something that episode is
small and this is what one over so the
gap between these two the promise gap is
like 1 over L cubed I have actually
recently proven that it's 1 over l
squared because you don't need to use
the geometric lemma we actually know
exactly what the eigenvectors are in
that subspace so basically the best
promised gift that you can get from a
construction is 1 over l squared that's
the promise gap it requires a small
epsilon but you can get it by amplifying
the original circuit and this
construction with this promise get also
applies to three local hamiltonian when
you use the construction that we have
come up with which I Moses sometime back
where we have a three local we make for
local projectors out of three local
culture
without any perturbation gadgets so this
is the promise gap and now we can go and
try to see what's what's beyond that
angle between the subspaces is not where
these eigenvectors all right it's also
the geometric dilemma is you're using
like the taking like what's the closest
from here what's the process from here
and what's the angle between but it
that's not an eigenvector so when you
actually find the eigen vector you see
that the gap is bigger that's that's all
there is to it so basically the bound is
not tight for this case and different
ways of rebounding the lowest energy of
like the term plus another term you can
find them in a david gossett or andrew
charles and zach web Swiper oh no on the
chemical cleaners of the balls Harvard
Model you can also find other limits
like that we have used in our quantum
reset ECM a complete paper and we're
looking for others that would be
applicable if anybody's interested in
that or has more knowledge about the
sons of two positive semi-definite
operators please come talk to me I'm
very interested ok let's continue we'll
continue on we had five local
Hamiltonian but we want to get lower
locality we want to get like something
there will be more physical something
they will actually have a nice geometry
and form that we will use projections
and gadgets so let's have a domain mole
for domain wall clock we knew that we
used a three local transition 100 goes
to 110 but what if we just use that
projection just one local meaning if it
happens here we're happy the call goes
forward as as we want but if it happens
dear here that's weird we don't really
want that to happen because that creates
a state that's not a clock state Solar
will do we'll just hit it with this so
we'll add terms to our Hamiltonian that
i really be and that hate bad domain
walls which means that that one just go
and hide in the corner because the
ground state cannot have any part of
that
any practice it means that if you have a
Hamiltonian that has small terms like
that and a really big terms like this
the ground state will be close to the
original ground state l we did it just
with one local projections and two local
checking terms why does this hand waving
our admit work it works because of the
projection link imagine I have a huge
Hamiltonian H tune that has a null space
and in space of excited states and now
I'll add a small term to it the spectrum
will split but it will split in such a
way when you look at the bottom of the
spectrum basically these bottom
eigenvalues are very close to the
eigenvalues of the little term
restricted to this subspace that's the
content of the projection level so the
eigenvalues of the actual hamiltonian
are very close to the eigenvalues of the
small hamiltonian restricted to here in
practice say i have this is my big term
and this is my little term now the
ground state subspace of this term are
good clock states good domain wall
States and now what will this term do
here within these states only not
forgetting about everything else because
if you move out your energy is high it
will just couple that I will couple
these so all together the ground state
will be just a unit from super
polarization of these it will not be
that exactly but it'll be really close
to it so to get from five local to 300
Hamiltonian you add very strong checks
like this and then you'll add terms that
now look slightly different if you are
interested in the details come talk to
me they're not projector anymore so
they're not positive semi-definite and
that's why this result was not showing
that 1 2 3 6pm a complete and restrict
it to good [ __ ] states have the analysis
just goes through as before it's a
quantum walk on the line
the next thing that we can do we can
introduce gadgets and this is where it
gets interesting how do we take a three
local Hamiltonian and you want to divide
it into two local interactions the way
to do it say that I want to interact
three things with the Zed Zed Zed
interaction I add some Unseelie terms in
between between these my little more
original cubits 1 2 3 and i'm
introducing on sale as a B and C I will
really strongly couple them meaning that
these two terms really like to point in
the same direction these two terms
really like to point in the same
direction and so on so basically the
ground state subspace of this one of
this big h is the span of 0 0 0 and 1 11
now i will add a little term it is like
ZX z x is NX what will happen you can do
the analysis with perturbation Theory
actually analyzing the resolve end
something like this and going to third
order by basically hand waving Lee what
can happen you can get contributions
they go like V but any v takes a state
and flips it which brings it away from
this small small subspace that's no good
you have turns in the second order where
you can have something that flips and
flips back these will need to be
subtracted and then in the third order
you'll get terms that go like ZZ z xxx
so we get the Zenta debt that we want
and an xxx which takes 0002 one more
month and which means that if actually
these until us are in the states 0 0 0
plus 1 11 what happens within that
subspace you get an effective
interaction that goes like this so
basically only in the third order all of
that can be flipped and that's when the
effective interactions around here will
be what we wanted so you get an
effective three local interaction from
two local interactions your life can be
made simpler low you can do it what's
here you really need very
strong interactions on a higher energy
scale so if you actually Reese Keller
Hamiltonian afterwards your gaps get
much smaller but you can do it with a
single until inside this is what I just
got in from it all from a discussion
with our you don't stop and he has a
paper about this about all kinds of
different gadgets that you can generate
he's here so talk to him where are you
there where for example one thing that
we have just come up with is that
imagine they have a very strong term
that like you want this until out to be
down 0 and then you have a term that
takes this and turns it around a third
of the way turns this around the third
of the way in turn this around the third
of the way and in the third order
perturbation theory you get you generate
this interaction and what we have traded
for is we don't have strong interactions
anymore we just have strong local fields
and interactions keep their strengths as
they were before so the second order
term imagine that here it's X and that
if they're Polly's so if they come if
you have it twice it's just an identity
so it's a constant so it's an overall
[ __ ] if you have something that's more
complicated then you really need to add
at terms that exactly cancel it out but
in this in this case the second order
term is just still nothing right
and there's more in results on these
gadgets if you look at special cases
where all the Hamiltons they want to
generate our in the same basis then
Jacob llaman de has exact gadgets that
work without perturbation theory but
that's only for special cases but
they're very interesting so those are
our resources but I have more questions
what could we do can we change how can
we change our hamiltonians further but
classically when we have an interaction
we can make the interaction stronger by
just like copying our information around
like for example if these needs want to
be equal then I make all of them I make
all of them want to be equal but what
can I do quantum can I even just put in
a single mediator cubed in between to
generate the same interaction and again
by discussing with you Dom I we have
figured out or he told me about that
basically if you put in a nun Scylla
here and make it really strong with a
really strong field you can generate in
second order perturbation theory the
effective interaction between these two
things okay so maybe it's also similar
to waterfest rotten shook are using
where you general in this so in these
from your models where like again like
you're generating an effective
interaction that's far away bye-bye
mediators
hey so if the devil's herd you can use
the adults iteratively so that you can
reduce k local terms to just two local
terms like this right but I would like
to get gadgets if they're a possible
then we'll work like intermediaries that
I could put in stuff in between that
wouldn't require these higher energy
scales that somehow wouldn't mess up
gaps and I don't know how to do it
alright next thing what we're going to
talk about is that there are trade-offs
between locality and dimensionality in
these quad constructions so maybe i'll
just show you a couple things as time is
running fast usually we have these clock
and work registers with ok so here
imagine that i have week terms that they
say these are on order one and these are
on the order of the size of the system
to the third to the third which means
that if i introduce this and I rescale
all my terms to order one two at most
order one if this was my effective
Hamiltonian with some gap then
everything gets squished by the order of
like all the size of the system cubed or
even more which means that if I had a I
had a Hamiltonian that a son gap I put
in gadgets I needed to make things
strong to make in the little system
everything work as I desired and then I
rescale the system back which means that
I have everything working as desired but
with a much smaller again again much
smaller I can value gap but when we
translate it to the promise gap it's the
remain small
but with these for example if you use
these non-perturbative gadgets by Jake
then you don't don't get but those are
kind of classical several of these
gadgets into your picture can you put
them all or many places yet each time
you your gear produces or just reduces
once just once but your again there to
go no no no it's not iteratively like
that no just so let's replace everything
by gadgets and then some of the things
are very strong so we just not rescale
at the end in peril and there won't be a
internet contribution and as you go up
to say fourth order then there will be
transitions that they involve more than
one answer and you have the inter gadget
much as far as
so if you go from cater to you go to
Kate order or k minus 1 order in
perturbation theory so I think it's like
all the well I don't know how to
translate sits where where the size of
the system comes in because that's where
you need to really prove what the
overall get is gonna be so number of
gadgets you have to put in ok there's
you know and choose three all right so
Daniel is saying that the size of the
system comes in open how many gadgets do
I put it is that it affects the new one
pretty great all right the defects the
normal the preparation meaning that like
in the end i'm looking at like the whole
hamiltonian i'm asking for the norm of
the whole big hamiltonian and the small
one and this one will have the number of
things done the per day has to be small
in norm right and so do that but it has
a lot of times yes to the norm is
proportional number
okay so to repeat that system size comes
in that my perturbation has a lot of
terms and it has to be small in our
compared to the rest so if this is a lot
than willing this needs to be much
bigger okay let's look into that to see
what was if anybody knows what's the
best gadget on the market please come
tell all right one of the things that I
like to do on the other hand is not to
go through the gadgets get it to part
but try to do this with that without
this and just basically trading locality
dimensionality and trying to get like
different clocks that would still work
without needing to like really punish
the big terms in a huge way so one thing
that's also interesting that in these
clockwork registers this clock feels
that they like interaction or the data
interacts with a lot of different cloth
qubits you can do it with constant
degree geometric locality imagining that
you have your places where your data
could be on a grid and then your clock
winding around this in space and as the
corn goes forward the computation goes
forward and as the clock goes here the
data moves so you can do this and all
together you have every particle
interacting with only a constant number
of other particles so this can be also
geometric with second thing you can
really get rid of this clockwork
registered idea and have a geometric
walk meaning that like really where the
date where the data is tells me what
time it is so I have I hope I don't know
whether actually people have built
computers in this way that it's like a
billiard ball that you have both model
where your balls coming through your
system and as they hit each other the
computation is happening and we can do
all this also as a clock construction
and this mean proposed by re Mizell
sometime way way back and then later
with Daniel Adar also dominic dancing
has looked at
similar models like this for programming
computation then a similar model was
used in the universality of elevated
computation by honorable phantom camp a
Landau Lloyd in the negev and then most
recently has been analyzed by liquid
rock Mannon or Barbara at their house
where they actually have shown what the
best gap for that is I'll tell you a
little bit about and then finally you
can do this type of construction where
you have data moving even in 1b not on a
2d grid and that's the paper by our
local does not Iranian campaign from
also I won't have time to tell you more
about that so to move data through your
system one idea that I really like is a
cute rate surfer so imagine do you have
a domain wall like microwave and there's
a surfer sitting on the wall the server
can move it's good because clock
checking is to local identification is
just looking at where the surface and
the projections that moves it differs
only at two sides so this will be useful
in some models and when you want to make
something more complicated you're
probably put in like somehow more were
stuck in but to have the data in there
somehow you need to increase the size of
your particles to carry and move the
data in your system in one day or in 2d
you need larger Kunitz or possible
larger locality of interactions so for
example this is a model that all are you
miss out this proposed and all because
recommended by batter how I've analyzed
that you have particles that come in
into it to gates that I've a grid and
they can go and jump together through
gate through these gates like this and
maybe they can go back and then they
don't really have to go in order they
can do whatever they want or and they
have to carry internal States because
they're qubits there are their spin up
or spin down plus they have a position
or you can encode instead internal
States into a dual rail encoding just
like you do in quantum optics basically
saying if a particle is flying this way
or this way this way it's a zero this
way it's a one and this has been used
for example in the universal
construction for x to walk by a David
David go sit in the child and Zach web
or also in the recent paper on
although you may completeness of the
boss huh burn for I won't tell you this
this is this different different clocks
one way that you can have the geometric
clock running 2d is you can have it in
sequence like this that first we go we
go down the row and remove the data and
we go down the road and move the data
this is we've been here we haven't been
here and this is where the data is and
this is where the active sport is and
this has been using the universal very
vertical it has two local interactions
six-dimensional units and in these
papers suddenly like tables like this
started to appear and they start to be
more and more complicated as you're
decreasing dimensionality and making
things simpler and less costly in
locality you can do different things
like where the qubits can go parallel
whatever they don't have to go at the
same time still they have to have a
structure we've been here we haven't
been here this is where the data is the
dynamics is like a string on a torus and
they have shown that this is human
complete Oh Nicholas in bad rap you need
for local operations you write it in
terms of fermions with spin or with
particles of spent three house which is
like dimension 4 and for local so this
is costly the motivation for this was to
give a new proof for universality of
adiabatic but you still need also a
particle tuning and all together they
showed a promise game platforms like n
to the minus 3 D to the minus 3 they
conjecture and they're working on a
proof that it's better that's n to the
minus 2 and e to the minus 2 which is l
to the minus 2 which i have already
shown you that you can get this from the
usual construction on the line so
there's no game here sorry oh D is the
depth of the circuit and n is the width
of the circuit because we were thinking
that like paralyzing the circuit you
could kind of I get something better
than just ordering the gates in order
but in the end the best you get and
we're not even there in this
construction yet is the size of the
circuit which is 10 times d squared in
the universe so again it's a
construction that goes like 1 over l
squared paralyzed
we'll show you this all right oh you you
can do stuff in one be with 13
dimensional particles or trading off
like parity and whatever with a
dimensional particles at the end and the
results the best things that we have
gotten is that 112-200 hamilton SQ m a
complete on a 2d grid with this
perturbation gadgets or on a line of a
dimensional states and then if you look
at an unforced rated problem it's qma
one complete on a line of 11 dimensional
states in any geometry of states that
are three-dimensional at five
dimensional interacting this is leonel
darlin or the dragon or quantum 3 says
it's cute qubits interacting three at a
time so this is asking about the ground
state energy of an alpha straightening
proper time is running out so if anybody
wants to learn more about color
constructions I have nice pictures and I
have much joy inventing different ones
which I won't tell you about this time
ok you might have seen some of that if q
IP like for example there's I'm asking
whether you can make a clock that's
shortly that will not run in a do not
need lq is like unity and the way to do
it like you have a clock that's for
example that has like two wheels so like
one wheel turns and the second clock
ticks neither wheel turns and the clock
ticks and so on and the way to do what
you get you get like with two things for
length see you get to c squared clock
states you get for local transition six
local gates and altogether the promise
gap stays whatever it was before so this
is just making smaller clothes and you
can do all kinds of other contexts but
oh the clock can be like if you make a
constant number of these cogs then the
clock can be just off length like a
constant root of the number of [ __ ]
states that you need to do okay so it
can be pretty small
I'll just in the picture i just drew too
because i want constant interaction
deval like i would consider interactions
so that the particle doesn't interact
with like with it and things or like no
I don't want any local interactions I
want to cook I want to constant K log of
interactions because what you need to do
it like you need to synchronize dance on
me like if this one is just finished
around then needs to go forward then
everything you need to do something with
the data so you need to look at two
things here two things here and a data
say so the more more cogs you have the
more particles you have to look at I
don't know what's what Logan local is
just like what your original key testing
before he went 2-5 walk away where your
clock is just like one two three four
five days that's log and local prove
anything else just the size of your
system is smaller but that's all I don't
know what what else could be good with
it one thing that we can do with Logan
local thing is what the eff has invented
is something an idling which like at the
end of your computation look like the
guy that was just like doing this and
not doing anything and not computing
anymore which somehow like increases the
way of the terms where the computation
is done you can do that with a logo
sighs cook all right let me give you a
couple of questions at the end and go to
Fernando so one question that i have
that is unresolved and i would like to
find out then the cute quantum pcp
conjecture there are two formulations
one is that could we possibly find a
local hamiltonian they will be still
cume complete even though it would have
a fractional promise kept meaning that
the gap would be a constant times the
number of terms or could it be that like
we could have proofs for qma where we
look only at a few qubits all the time
at a country this way it's known because
you would take the ground state and then
you will check the ground state but this
way I don't know how to do it me neither
like can I translate random small
verification this into here like how I
do I actually make up these clocks I'd
really don't know how to do it so this
is this comes from a discussion with
math in shorts and he has been thinking
about this quite a bit okay I would
really want want to know and learn to
learn about this if any more people want
to know about this let's try to set up a
time we doing in the seven-year-old like
I think this is the small thing like
it's a wheel by a quantum reduction I'd
never you know you can't find the
content reduction anyway okay good one
one thing not another question that i
have is well if we were thinking about
the quantum vcp theorem they'd like to
possibly the local Hamiltonians ground
states would need to be very intended so
can we check them by just looking at
things locally what if the state's
themselves are topological then I know
that I cannot distinguish them locally
but again donut and Leo will are
thinking about this with their local
each a couple coats and maybe they will
lead somewhere then I'll give you
another question all these constructions
have a Pauline on one of a polynomial
promise gap that one that does not allow
us to make it any bigger can we come up
with gadgets that would be consistent
like interactions possibly effective
interaction generated that like the
interaction will get stronger so i could
make gaps bigger or like make things
more more frustrating in the null case
would i do it with some kind of gadgets
that will be based on air quantum error
correction codes and could we just come
forget about the clock instructions
overall and just use some direct methods
that does really look at the hamiltonian
and don't think about encoding
computation it anymore and this is what
eat i was supposed to be talking about
here the for example if you have a
matrix that's made out of a hamiltonian
and then you look at a high power so
there's an interactive proof that
somehow you can convince you about what
the trace of this is which is related to
the smallest eigen value of that
hamiltonian and this was one of the
steps that is taking place in the proof
of the classical visit convention i
won't believe and give you that and I'll
just end up here with I try to tell you
about we will how we will like strong
but the problem is that we have small
eigenvalue gaps and we don't know how to
transfer get one from the other told you
a bit about the history states and how
do we construct clocks and then ended up
with questions that's it so so he's a
clock the most prominent parted types
construction meaning that if people
design a better clock then you could
decrease the eigen value gap or or the
other parts all right so the eigen value
get the promise get really comes from
the clock and we don't know how to
compare states like encode computation
without actually having a label without
having that core and the best at the
clock the best work that we know is a
line where the gap is 1 over N squared
when this is a number of steps and we
know how to implement it locally now so
I think that we have reached the limit
there so even with like better locality
something we cannot make this better
at the moment maybe somebody will come
up with them we're focusing a lot on
this gap above the ground space around
state so we're very nice meat grown
stick man anything else you living as I
don't want to see and you're trying to
get this cup yeah is there any sense in
which it could be helpful to allow for
more degenerate ground face over we also
have a bunch of excited states which are
all find it sort of hope we'll have no
energy there and then the gap is
somewhere further up something really
bad happens and then you have gone if
you wear visually you start on quantum
computation and you'd say you know I
mean it's fine if we skip a step or
something that that's okay this is a
tiny bit about the ground state but it's
okay with allow that as a witness as
well and we'll be trying to enforce the
large gap you know somewhere else okay
so so Thomas asking what would happen if
we had like a principle this would be
not just the states that are exactly
zero says but maybe a few about that as
well and we wouldn't be carrying about
the gap here which is small but about
the higher gap that's in there that
maybe comes from an error correcting
code and this is possible and this would
be interesting because for example even
here we're getting like a small promise
gap just because we're looking at the
possible xmas excitation and eigen value
in there but we've even seen that in the
geometric lemma that was not the thing
that we needed to do also when you do
universality of adiabatic you're looking
at a gap that's kind of small but that's
not the relevant gap because the
relevant gap actually there is naught 2
1 over N squared by it's one or M or
even a constant gap there just again you
get a proof that you can show that the
gap is small and the house all you need
to go but exciting to these states is
not harmful also there's another paper
by Stephen Drew edifying Peter sure
where they look at all try to find error
correcting codes for adiabatic and there
they can correct against 1 & 2 2 cubed
noise and get a constant gap for that
for the price of locality but it's not a
universal thing it just goes up to only
to some
some errors so I don't really know what
it would translate to hear but I think
this is a very good idea so try relax
this a bit and try and look for a bigger
gap somewhere somewhere about it
definitely so maybe a comment on that so
in kitaev pot construction history
station sharpen the low-lying states
that are not history states are kind of
similar they look like history stick at
different phases so if you look at just
one of those stay that looks like yeah
should actually be fine too the problem
is that when you start taking
superpositions of those different states
you can get history that you know goes
for a while and then just stops in the
middle of the computation and so even
though the eigenstates look ok there are
superpositions of different eigen states
that are actually bad so that guy has no
energy which is not really end
regardless of what happens but it gets
accepted so just hear these eigenvalues
eigenvectors here they go like e to the
minus IP s this so the universal
position just has once and these ones
have phases that change but if you put
them together you can you get just stuck
somewhere and that could be a problem
and then again if your hematoma is not
precise and you can you have a whole
nother slow problems that comes in
thank you